upon us young brothers fate shall yet
smile our enemies will perish like dew
in the morning sun
the words of the ukrainian national
anthem
[Music]
the choir wears national dress at this
ceremony in a park in the eastern city
of kharkiv
the gathering was held to mark what the
ukrainian president vladimir zielinski
called a day of unity
the flag was raised from half-mast
soldiers stood to attention
after the national anthem a singer tried
to rouse the crowd with a popular song
about morale and peace
[Music]
but only a few people came to watch
after posing for photographs the choir
began to leave
joy for the unity of our country we want
to be united we want to be very united
nearby outside the tent where for years
people have signed up for the army and
donated money a poster of the russian
president and his belarusian ally and
fellow neighbor of ukraine but the city
is calm
it's quiet as usual it's just a normal
routine day people working children at
school i don't know
what will be will be i am not worried
there is no point in worrying
on a day when u.s intelligence services
predicts a possible russian invasion of
ukraine a show of unity here in the
eastern city of kharkiv amongst a small
group of people and their message is
that ukraine remains unified against
what they and the government and their
western backers say
is russian aggression chance stratford
al jazeera kharkiv